ja wir führen den Krieg gegen einen
Rohstoff riesen rohstoffriesen Russland
und während ich das Buch geschrieben mal
recherchiert habe ist klar geworden wir
sind verdammt schlecht vorbereitet auf
einen Wirtschaftskrieg 16 Jahre Merkel
die Bilanz muss man glaube ich noch mal
neu schreiben wir haben kritische
Infrastruktur Gasspeicher Öl raffinerin
direkt in die Hände von russischen
staatskonzernen gegeben äh an rostnheft
an gastron das muss die neue Regierung
jetzt gerade ausbügeln äh müssen die
übernehmen wir haben vor lauter Sparbuch
die Energiewende verpennt darüber haben
wir eben schon gesprochen werden wir bei
Wind werden wir bei Solar schon weiter
statt die schwarze Null z.B im Haushalt
anzustreben äh dann wären heute die
Preise günstiger wäre die Inflation
nicht so hoch würde es uns besser gehen
und wir haben ein Problem dass der
deutsche Immobilienmarkt immer noch ein
Gangsters Paradise ist ein Geld welche
Paradies Geldwäsche Paradise locken
natürlich auch russische Oligarchen mit
schmutzigen Geld an und deswegen wenn
russische Oligarchen sanktionieren will
dann muss man wissen wem gehört die
Yacht wem gehört die Immobilie wenn man
das nicht weiß dann tappen die Ermittler
im Dunkeln und genau das ist der Fall
deswegen also wir sind schlecht
vorbereitet wie kommen wir da raus ist
jetzt sehr wichtige Frage wir müssen
beim Thema Geldwäsche ganz viel anpacken
ist diese Woche im Bundestag sanktions
durchsetzungsgesetz müssen 6 ein neues
Gesetz für machen und vor allem und das
ist dann noch mal der Bogen wir müssen
eine investitionsoffensive von der Rampe
schieben nicht sparen wie Christian
Lindner sagt nicht an der schönen Bremse
festhalten sondern alles tun um Gebäude
energetisch zu sanieren um Wind und
Solar auszubauen damit wir unabhängig
werden von Putins Gas und auch von
Katars Gas außerdem
den letzten Teil hätte ich eigentlich am
Anfang fast nur nicken können aber die
Schuldenbremse ist gerade in der Zeiten
wie jetzt zentral für solide
Staatsfinanzen auch in der Zukunft für
das Thema Generation Gerechtigkeit wir
dürfen ja nicht außer Acht lassen haben
bei Corona ja schon fast eine
halbe Billion an Schulden aufgenommen
und jetzt mit den ganzen Rettungspaketen
ist es und im Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr und der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse sind sehr fast noch mal
eine Billion an Schulden wo
ehrlicherweise stand heute ja auch
keiner beantworten kann bis wann die
zurückgezahlt sind und deswegen ist die
Schuldenbremse nicht ein Fetisch dieser
Regierung sie steht in der Verfassung
das ist eine Verfassungsgebot an die
sich der Gesetzgeber erhalten muss und
die Schuldenbremse heißt ja auch nicht
keine neuen Schulden wir machen trotzdem
45 Milliarden Euro weitere Schulden in
diesem Bundeshaushalt wie investieren ja
und jetzt zu sagen wir machen einfach
die Schleusen auf führt nicht dazu das
zielgerichtet investiert wird sondern
das Geld für Dinge ausgegeben wird die
man schon immer irgendwie gut fand die
aber mit der Krise hat sich wenigstens
aber mal ehrlich also gerade die FDP die
hält sich will die Schulden wenn sie
jetzt formal einhalten aber neben der
Schulden da haben sie so viele
nebenhaushalte 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr kein Problem haben wir raus
Doppel Wumms 200 Milliarden kein Problem
haben wir raus also die Schuldenbremse
ist durchlöcher die ist hintergangen
weil sie nicht in die Zeit passt das
müssen Sie leider irgendwann anerkennen
da müssen Sie die Zeichen der Zeit
erkennen das Problem ist auch wenn wir
übernächste Generation sprechen nicht
erben vererben die sozusagen staatliche
Schulden die außerdem auch gleich
privates Vermögen sind sondern zwei
Seiten einer Medaille sondern haben wir
einen Tag der Wirtschaft und gerade
sehen wir 10% Inflation wir sehen
Produktionsstopp und das hat damit zu
tun wie ich eben erklärt habe dass wir
in der Vergangenheit nicht investiert
haben wir haben eine Milliarden schweren
Investitionen in diesem Land ja gut
können wir diesen Wirtschaftskrieg
überhaupt gewinnen
ein bisschen über dieses kriegerische
Wirtschaftskrieg wirklich ganz kräftige
trommelt werden das finde ich schon ein
bisschen merkwürdig Zitate natürlich
sagen ja ich kenne das ja selbstständig
ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich die
richtige
Strategie ist da ein Wirtschaftskrieg
reinzugehen ich meine zuerst mal schauen
was hat das für Folgen für die
Bevölkerung hier und das kümmert
offenbar diese wirtschaftskriege nicht
und dann muss ich doch daran erinnern
dass nicht einfach jeder der in Russland
Geld hat und das sogenannte alligat
verstehen wir jetzt einfach jetzt ein
Handlanger des Systems ist auch ein
Kriegstreiber das sind oft einfach
pauschale Annahmen wir haben ein
Rechtsstaat hier und ich möchte da hin
dass wir den einhalten auch gegenüber
russischen Bürgen ich staune dass
Deutschland die EU die Schweiz übrigens
auch der staunlich selbst dass ich sage
nicht dass die Schweiz der beste ist
überhaupt nicht dass wir da natürlich
hingehen und sagen russische Leute keine
Visa mehr zu teilen einfach pauschal das
ganze Verband dass das geht doch nicht
immer wir haben auf der Welt haben wir
dutzende Kriege ständig und jetzt bei
diesem Krieges plötzlich alles anders
das sind nur die Bösewichte was sonst
auf der Welt passiert ist scheißegal
Entschuldigung für die direkte Sprache
wir pilgen da oder der deutsche
Wirtschaft zum klimaminister nach Kata
macht ein wirklich das ist natürlich
auch ein Unrecht Team in Saudi-Arabien
dasselbe das Zelt plötzlich nicht mehr
das ist ein dermaßen einseitige
verblendete Politik da kann ich nicht
mitmachen ich finde müssen eine Politik
machen die nicht nur mit dem Zeigefinger
auf andere zeigt sondern die schaut das
hier alles richtig funktioniert und
dieser Wirtschaftskrieg ist nicht das
was für die Bürger besser macht das ist
hier funktioniert also im Prinzip weiter
Ausgaben machen weiter einfach Geld
drucken oder nein gar nicht nein nein
ich bin da bin ich völlig beim mfdp
Politiker selbstverständlich bei der
Straße also Schuldenbremse ist ein sehr
ideales Konzept selbstverständlich
braucht wir müssen keine Schulden machen
dass das kommt da auf unsere Kinder zu
das ist einfach eine Politik ja das eine
Auge zu macht ich meine linke Politik
heißt eigentlich Geld ausgeben dass man
selbst nicht verdient hat und das ist
sicher keine
nachhaltige Politik in Schwaben hat man
ein bisschen eine andere Einstellung zum
zum schwäbischen Haushalten und das ist
sicher die vernünftige Art wie man auch
in der Politik umgeht also sie würden
jetzt sagen wir haben in Deutschland
Schulen auch
den Schulen die sind katastrophalen
Zustand wir haben brückenstraßen im
katastrophalen Zustand wir sind abhängig
von fossilen Importen ölgas Kohle aus
dem Ausland wir sind abholen Zustand
weil sie irgendwie ein bisschen Öl
importieren das ist kein kausaler wir
sind im schlechten Frage
haben und da muss man schon beantworten
wo kommt
das Geld ausgeben das sind eben ganz
wenige zentrale Dinge und wenn die
Bildung beim Start ist dann soll er das
machen aber man kann die Bildung nach
privatisieren aber es wird so viel Geld
zum Fernsehen ausgeworfen beim Start ich
meine das überhaupt keine Ausgaben
Disziplin vorhanden zum Beispiel die
Verwaltung die wächst überproportional
das wächst viel schneller Wirtschaft
selbstständig das ist ja unglaublich das
Buch nur so aus der Stadt ist wirklich
nicht der der zum Geld schauen kann die
Fahrt Leute was mir im Griff stellen
sich mal vor im Privatbereich wenn sie
so eine Schuldenwirtschaft machen
dann sind sie schnell weg vom Fenster
und auch vom Leben
weil damit alles durcheinander
geschmissen Gemüsebrühe drauf umgerührt
und raus also da ist keine Substanz
dahinter wenn ich mal sagen weil das
einfach alles durch so alles alles
gesund aber er Gemüsebrühe ist gesund
privatisierte Bildung da kann man andere
Länder gucken dass es nicht besonders
gesund aber es geht ja ums Thema am
besten Universitäten sind glaube ich
private Welt weil die sind nicht in
Deutschland
leben dann können sie nicht so eine
Bruchbude haben wie dann vielleicht die
freien Städte in Berlin das sieht nicht
die besten Leute ja also ich glaube es
Wettbewerb sie sind auch im geistigen
ist das beste auch ein Talkshow Webseite
der besten Argumente Sportlichkeit das
ist das was anderes
sagt wenn die Mehrheit der Bürger das
will dass der Staat die Bildung bezahlt
da können sie auch zum Beispiel
Bildungsgutscheine machen und jede
auswählen kann ich möchte diesen
Schultyp oder diesen das heißt nicht
dass man nichts kriegt aber es gibt
bessere Systeme Bildung ist ja gar nicht
unser Thema gerade sondern die
Wirtschaft Frau jung sagen Sie uns
einmal befürchten sie in
Wohlstandsverlust wir haben über die
Apotheken gesprochen aber sie jetzt als
Privatperson als Bürgerin
natürlich hat man die Angst dass dass es
nicht so schön weitergeht wie es auch
bis jetzt ist ich sehe das aber auch vor
allen Dingen bei den vielen Kunden in
meiner Apotheke das da eine große Angst
ist und ich frage mich halt auch wie
viele
oder welcher Teil der Bevölkerung
überhaupt in so ein Wirtschaftskrieg mit
reingehen wollte mit Russland ne die
kleinen Leute sind ja gar nicht gefragt
worden wir sind ja die die ganz unten an
der Kette sind und wir haben die ganzen
Probleme jetzt wir haben zu wenig ja wir
haben die
Energiepreissteigerung keine Medikamente
das Essen wird teurer also ich unten an
der Basis ich komme ja mit auch ganz
vielen einfacheren Leute zusammen und
ich höre mir halt deren Sorgen an und
die Sorgen sind bestimmt nicht die ob
Herr Putin jetzt den Krieg da weiter
führt oder nicht sondern die Sorgen
stehen halt hier vor der Haustür und
glauben Sie was schildern Ihnen die
Menschen dass die Politik Herr Straße
der sich selber mit ins Boot holen dass
die Politik diese Sorgen hört fühlen
sich die Menschen da aufgehoben gehört
wahrgenommen das kann ich nicht
beurteilen ich kann nur von mir aus
sagen dass ich finde dass wir nicht
erhört werden
der Bundestag wäre nicht bewusst was in
unserem Land abgegeben was bei den
Energiepreisen passiert wir machen sein
um dreiviert ja ja nicht anders als
Krisenmanagement wir haben drei drei
entlassungspakete geschnürt wie machen
gerade hochkomplexe Gaspreis und
strompreisbremse das wird nicht zu
führen dass die Leute
genauso leben können wie vor diesem
Krieg das behauptet aber auch keiner wir
versuchen gerade mit allen Ebenen und
allen Maßnahmen diese Preise dämpfen
natürlich aufzählen aber Frau junge
die Ukraine angegriffen hat sondern
Putin Putin hat diesen Krieg gestartet
und das ist auch ein Teil unserer
Freiheit die da verteidigt wird das ist
ja dass du so nach dem Motto das ist
jetzt eher nicht unser Problem was da
eine Ukraine ist das hört man ja bei
manchen immer wieder in den
Zwischentönen doch es ist unser Problem
was da eine Ukraine passiert weil es
nicht irgendwo auf der Welt ist sondern
direkt vor unserer Haustür und ich spüre
immer noch eine große Solidarität die
auch in Umfragen messbar ist bei den
Leuten die sagen das ist eine schwierige
Situation für uns alle gemeinsam
insbesondere für die Menschen die wenig
Geld haben dadurch den Winter kommen zu
kommen das zu bezahlen und deswegen
haben wir ja auch die diese Pakete
geschnürt aber ich will auch sagen nicht
wir haben das Gas abgestellt sondern
Putin hat seine Waffe eingesetzt wir
haben uns abhängig gemacht von
russischem Gas in den letzten Jahren
obwohl wir seit 2014 ja eigentlich die
Warnung hatten ja mit nach der Annektion
der Grimm auch wir haben noch zu
Produktionszeiten im Deutschen Bundestag
nachdem man versucht hat von russischer
Seite anderen Ländern in Osteuropa das
Gas die Gaslieferung zu reduzieren haben
wir gesagt lasst uns Moratorium bei
nordstream 2 machen das entwickelt sich
in eine Richtung die wir nicht begrüßen
können die damalige Bundesregierung hat
darauf nicht gehört und jetzt sind wir
in der Situation in der Version und wir
müssen die jetzt lösen wir waren das
schon ernst nehmen was zwei junge sagt
oh ich meine hier geht's konkret im
Kaufkraft Verlust wir haben Probleme die
normale Bevölkerung Probleme sie können
die Gasheizung
auch immer nicht mehr bezahlen
Inflation herrscht gleichzeitig das
macht die Kaufkraft noch Schwäche und da
würde ich find ich schon ein bisschen ja
bisschen einfach nur pauschale Vorwürfe
Politik ich glaube die Leute in diesem
Land die haben echte Probleme hatten ja
nichts für Menschen gerade
haben wir nicht geschaffen Probleme
seine falsche Politik diese nachher
wieder mit staatlichen Programme also
Ihre Antwort ist keine Sanktionen
gegenüber russ
ja ich finde das Sanktionen in der
Geschichte ich bin Historik von Haus aus
ich habe das studiert sehr oft nicht das
gebracht haben was nicht davon
versprochen hat das ist die Meransen
anderen Ländern so das ist vermutlich
auch in Russland so es gibt eine
teilwirkung der Sanktion aber sie haben
nicht dieses dieses Potenzial dass man
sich am Anfang davon versprochen hat und
oder sie treffen oft auch die Phasen ich
habe sehr gute Bekannte in Russland
übrigens auch in Ukraine auf beiden
Seiten und wenn sie ich habe das schon
mal gesagt und ähnliche Stelle wenn Sie
eine Rente haben von 200 € und dann ist
plötzlich nicht mehr möglich dass sie
Austausch haben aus dem Ausland das
bekannt in Geld überweisen können dann
haben Sie ein Problem und das trifft
auch einfach gebürtel und es ist ganz
schwierige Sanktionen so präzise zu
machen das wirklich die verantwortlich
für diesen kriegte
kritisieren
also das System
genau
identifizieren können
nicht jeder oligarette ist ein kriegst
aber das wurde ganz kleine Geheimdienst
Kreisen wurde diese Krise verschlossen
nicht auflösen ich will noch einmal
aufmerksam machen ja Wirtschaftskrieg
ihr neues Buch von Maurice Höfgen es
zeigen wir noch mal gibt's jetzt schon
zu kaufen oder haben
nein nein
sie dieses Thema weiter interessiert
hier in dieser Sendung haben wir es groß
angeschnitten haben diskut